he's got his own show andhe's owned in
Westwood one every day from 10:00 a.m.
the noon eastern time he's America's
Sweetheart Pat McAfee how are you pat
rich I'm much better now that I just
heard that incredible introduction from
one of the goats in the sports
talking-head world
I appreciate your love every time you
have a job you know that Pat you know
that you know that we're we're we're
we're cut from a similar cloth even
though people would not believe that
just on its own face Pat you know what I
mean we are well I mean you want to
Michigan I went to West Virginia yes you
are very sophisticated I got a little
less juice in the booth but hey the fact
that we both have appreciation for ball
kickers and solid personalities our moms
would say that makes us a win-win and a
match made in damn heaven well let's go
straight to the heart of the brand just
to start things off Pat you know and you
mentioned the word goat drew brees is a
goat
he's a first-ballot hall-of-famer he's
one of the all-time great purdue
boilermakers he gave a great speech to
the team it was brought in on his bye
week to Purdue delivered a great speech
prior to Purdue going out and and
beating Nebraska I just want to play a
quick portion of it right now as he went
after a very impassioned story talking
about he met his wife there and what
Purdue means to him went position by
position group and we sliced it up as he
went position by position group
addressing the team roll it where's my
DBS man you got stuck you guys got a
play with swagger today linebackers get
somebody man wide receivers man make
that play running backs man I love you
boys
cubies we throw darts man both balls
don't touch the ground tight ends maybe
the best athletes on the field we asked
you to do everything man oh line you
control the game all times dance I would
say I fear you guys D tackles man you
hold strong you hold the fort down
defining moment today if you're written
to give you to class you wouldn't give
it to class let's go Pat - claps that's
one clamp for each position group he
kind of left out wouldn't you say Pat
yeah you know drew brees is this
incredible quarterback
his motivational speeches before NFL
games when he's in the huddle of the
Saints there's enough for me two for you
three the whole thing's going it's it's
nothing short of mesmerizing and then
walking into that boiler up locker room
we all knew what was going to happen he
was gonna give an impassioned speech a
note kids we're gonna go one through a
wall and get a win against Nebraska and
he left out arguably the two most
important positions on the entire team
and I would say it's because of this yes
drew Brees is a very smart man not easy
to graduate from Purdue it's a bunch of
nerds there he knows that the kickers
and punters don't need to be motivated
he knows that kickers and punters are
going to show up every week and do their
job he knows that unlike all the other
position groups they kick some partners
for the Purdue Boilermakers we're gonna
ball out against the brass just so we
just didn't waste his breath he said
listen let's get right to the claps
let's get right to the antics let's get
right to the lip codes we don't need to
motivate those who are already
self-motivated and that's what kickers
and punters are because not only does
Drew Brees leave us off list a lot of
times talking heads do very much unlike
yourself retries hashtag for the brand
everybody that's my crop to be able to
handle that we're having our fun but
could you could you imagine you're one
of the punters or kickers in that room
as the goat goes position by position
then gets to the collapse oh my gosh did
you imagine I wish you would a rich eye
West Virginia he woulda came in there
what would happen what would happen I
mean I mean it's not often you get to
get motivated by one of the greatest
players of all time how would you give
me a little speech about makeup or
massage hey drew you robbed my friend
Pat actually of a Super Bowl with your
baby there his rookie year down in Miami
is there any way to potentially give me
a motivational speech from through a
little one-on-one little side combo here
or do you are you a position is Drew do
you hate dick there's a bunny because
that's the deal drew man one of my
favorite tweets of yours this season I
haven't brought this up to you was when
when they showed rich rod in the booth
okay he's an OC right now and what he's
on all misses easy it says that where is
the OC where is Rick
right now an Ole Miss and they showed
him he got so angry and upset it was
unlike a camera and what did you tweet
you tweeted something about like that
you've been there or done that what was
that about that was fantastic
do you remember that what you saw that
exactly that is a Rich Eisen
or that's the original Rich Eisen that
is the Rich Rodriguez staple right there
the look away yell he's so angry he
wants to yell so loud but he has to look
down and away from you so he doesn't
just project all of his spit on you and
he's so mad that is something that I've
been on the other end a couple of times
in front of that Purdue was that he
heard five different stories about what
happened last night I had a team
camaraderie building barbecue at my
house it was not a party he told me
straight to my face I was not allowed to
have any party so I did not have a party
I had a team camaraderie building
barbecue at my house it started at 8:00
p.m. it ended at like 2:00 a.m. yeah but
nonetheless team camaraderie builder and
three of my teammates left that party
and got arrested later that evening so
the next morning I had to go in and he
pulled me into his office and it was
that same reaction from that video you
saw of him in the booth punching air
yelling and he said I've heard three
points damn stories about what happened
last night and they all started your
mother trucking house and I I had to
tell them that I have a duplex connected
to my house they were having the party
so I can understand where the confusion
is and he made me run the steps to the
stadium for two weeks so he would not
accept the the the issue of the detail
that couldn't be your house because you
actually lived in a duplex he did not
accept that pact he rejected well the
issue with this is the fire marshal got
called to this party every police
officer in Morgantown was called to this
party they let us have it so my story
did not check out with literally of
anybody of authority that had to run
though I mean I thought it was valid
though
some houses that were connected and I
was having the barbecue they were having
a party but I could easily see how the
fire marshal the chief and sheriff would
all be confused about that here on the
Rich Eisen show all right man that's why
I call you America's Sweetheart Pat that
is just fantastic let's get to some of
the news of the day here cam is done for
the year he was put on IR about 40
minutes before we started talking and
and Glazer is pointing out the team can
save 19 million bucks by cutting or
trading him on just one last year on his
contract do you think he's played his
last game for the Carolina Panthers Pat
I do believe so I mean Elizabeth Frank
is a tough lady to deal with to begin
with and I think whenever the Carolina
Panther offense it's on a spark when
Kyle Allen got in there it was almost
like the writing was on the wall there
this is Christian McCaffrey team now
it's no longer Tam Newtons and I think
Cam Newton was an incredible quarterback
for the Carolina Panthers a lot of great
things came to the Carolina Panthers
organization with Cam Newton under the
helm but for me he's a completely
different player now he doesn't seem
like he loves it as much I get a chance
to watch him play against our team on a
Monday night football down Carolina in
the middle of a rainstorm and he was
loving football he was loving his
position he was basically the guy that
stands in front of an orchestra on waves
the two sticks I don't notice I guess
it's a pretty important position what's
that called the the guy that yeah what's
his name just a maestro there yes okay
very good
he was the maestro by the way that's a
real position I've learned for telling
this story I thought they just stood up
there and clapped their hands on beats
but he was like the maestro of the
entire city of the entire organization
they're playing the Superman theme song
he was diving over people he was
celebrating touchdowns for like two
minutes long while extra points were
being kicked he was taking the ball to
the crowd I mean it was it was a show it
was a spectacle and then something
happened and I do believe it all tracks
back to whatever Von Miller stripped
that ball from him it stripped his
happiness he seems like he's a
completely different player he doesn't
seem like he loves the game as much and
now the offerings at the beginning of
the year with him at the helm it seems
like a dull one Kyle Allen comes in
ignites something like the spark in that
offense they get going
Christian McCaffrey gets an MVP
conversation so now not only
business-wise did help them the release
Cam Newton 19 million I think for Cam
Newton it'll be good for him too he has
to go somewhere he's a super competitive
guy you have to reprove himself not just
on the field when he's playing but also
in meeting rooms in the way in the
weight room I think a new place could be
very good for Cam Newton I thought they
were gonna trade him they did not but I
don't think we've seen the end of Camden
football career but I do believe it's
the last time we've ever seen him with a
panther uniform on so it seems that he's
going to be available in March Pat so
the question is if nothing changes
between now and March in Chicago would
you say goodbye to true Biscay and bring
in Cam Newton yea or nay would you do
that
yeah yeah I mean we've all seen yes I
mean the Bears the Bears fans - they got
a ride-or-die with their people they
were behind this works for Biscay for a
while then they got off the Mitchell too
risky bandwagon now it's kind of like
everybody's against Nagy because he's
not drawing up the proper plays I mean
last year Mitchell travesty was the
number three overall QB our quarterback
this year he's next to dead last and
he's never just out of the pocket when
last year he had a lot of success so a
lot of people think weight is Nagy
tanking for true Biscay is he making him
look fat and not putting him in good
positions nobody really knows but it's a
very different quarterback from last
year Mitchell true Biscay and with that
defense whenever they're playing good
they are dominant you get a quarterback
that can run the ball and make some
plays like cam dude if use the Cam
Newton the VOAD it seems like a match
made in heaven especially for the fans
that scream they're bad they would love
candy up there so is it have you heard
of that before I mean I just want to
make sure you're just where a coach
doesn't like the quarterback anymore and
he feels that he's you know let's just
say he's a reigning coach of the year
and he's got some sort of status that he
would start exposing his own quarterback
to to get rid of him without actually
happened no I've never heard that my
entire life these are the things that
are said on the internet rich in the
internet it's never wrong before I move
on to another topic I should just make
sure that that everyone understands
Elizabeth Frank is not say the name of
the cap ologist
in in Carolina you just used the full
name of what you think is Liz Frank
although Liz Frank is not a woman but
rather the last name of the male doctor
who discovered the part of the foot
where this injury takes place and thus
was named after him right you were that
way but when his family came to America
it was actually Elizabeth Frankie's last
name they shortened it down to lives
Frank so depends on how deep you really
go into the investigation tear risk
nevertheless Elizabeth branch is a
terrible person in the foot
speaking of foot you sat next to Rex
Ryan when he made a reference to his
suppose it situation and the look on
your face on get up Pat I had to freeze
it
I had to freeze it and take a snapshot
of it you were you were a mood you've
got you're gonna you're my mood for that
sort of stuff that was amazing I
appreciate that give it up it's just I
mean it's awesome
it is dude it's a whole different style
of talking sports than I've ever done in
my life and that's director Ryan who is
a legend I have a blast in there man
it's very early though so I'm wide open
a little bit loopy normally so in a
moment let it rip what a moment that was
do you like to move to foals
instead of Minshew that was just made
about an hour before we started talking
Pat do you like that yeah so interesting
right because I mean Houston Texans over
there and London sound which by the way
every time I get a chance to listen to
you call a game with three other humans
in the booth yes which is not easy at
all you handle that thing in a beautiful
fashion you deserve a lot more credit
than you get for calling games those
waking up with you and the boys over
there is a thing of beauty I wish we
could do more often
bless you me too thank you for saying
that I appreciate it I thought with
Grace and just you know a little
humility and you never gonna point out
that I thought you know Carlos Hyde was
Duke Johnson and it's tough to see
Watson has the ball or not and I'm 50
years old it's webley's done
that's money well you mooch you lose
Curtin Irv have a beautiful chemistry
and it's I feel like I learned and I
enjoy the game from a completely serious
point you do a great job in there and
with Gardner Minshew yes I mean this has
been an interesting phenomenon here I
mean let alone the George in the
moustache and the incredible personality
and the ability to win games for the
Jaguars out of nowhere they paid both a
lot of money and I think the foulest
thing might go down is one of the most
interesting careers in the history of a
quarterback that is one of Super Bowl I
mean most Super Bowl quarterbacks or
Super Bowl MVPs everything like that
kind of a standard blueprint you get
drafted to a team you do well there you
win or you go to another team and you
become the head guy and you win there
for him it's just like he was never
really the guy and then he almost quit
had a kumbaya situation out in the woods
with his brother-in-law comes back goes
on this miraculous run his organization
says we're gonna go with the guy who
always gets hurt over you send him down
to Jacksonville gets paid and he gets
hurt while playing very well and another
guy gets hot in his replacement I mean I
don't know I think you're off to a good
start if you have Nick Foles a
quarterback I think big Richard Nick and
really do some things if he gets going
but I think gardner minshew is gonna be
a pretty hot topic on the trade market
this upcoming offseason if he's
available so I think the Jaguars got a
lot to figure out but a plethora of
quarterbacks is not a bad thing to have
last one for you Pat we started the
conversation with kickers and goats and
the goat kicker missed one in a matter
that it's so rare to see him miss period
let alone miss as Adam Vinatieri did you
represented him obviously and on game
day College GameDay at his alma mater
expertly I might add a couple of weeks
ago should I be concerned about Adam
Vinatieri how concerned should I be
right now about the goat Pat yeah I mean
I think he's not hitting the ball as
clean as you would hope for him to be
hitting the ball and as clean as he has
in the past and I even acknowledged that
during that game during the few
he wasn't hitting the ball exactly clean
you send a little bit fat but a lot of
tickers can hit the ball fat in the ball
goes through the uprights so I think
that last one when it came down to a
game time to win the game a minute 15
left or whatever it is soon as he
dropped on the field no matter how he
has had or how he has hit the ball
throughout the day none of that matters
because he's gotten better Terry he's
the goat he's gonna step up and hit this
ball through and then once you see the
entire operation happen with the laces
back and he gets a little bit chunky
with it I mean it was just a recipe for
disaster there and I'm definitely
worried about him but I'm worried about
the entire operation and Luke Rhodes is
an incredible long snapper he knows that
he didn't get the laces right there
Rigoberta Sanchez was an incredible
punter and a good holder he knows that
he didn't help out there by moving the
laces straight back and then he could
have made up for them all if he makes a
quick adjustment but he couldn't do that
so I think I'll be excited to see how
that unit bounces back after a rough
outing in Pittsburgh but I really like
this coach team I like them a lot in
military definitely gonna have to get
back on a hot streak if they're gonna
want to make a run well you know that
said though having seen deshaun Watson
with my own two eyes calling a very
choppy game on NFL Network Pat you know
it's tough to think the Colts are gonna
take that division though I haven't seen
that in person yeah I beat him though
I mean I'm something that folks have
done they had they are built for success
to something happen with the offensive
line the past couple weeks I mean if
that offensive line can get back on
track and still be the road Ritter's
that they were for the first you know
quarter of this season I think they're
set up for success if you can run the
ball and stop the run late in the year
in December in January that's what makes
the winning team and the Pacers have
been incredible at that for a long time
so the AFC is always gonna run through
them but the Houston Texans Colts game
is definitely gonna be pretty vital but
I like the way that Chris Ballard has
built the Colts and to be honest it's
good that the Shawn Watson is all the
way back because having the Houston
Texans be good at football is good for
the game and I enjoy watching him play
he's he's a Magic Maker out there he
looks like a human joysticks is to make
all the throws kicked in the face
thought he lost his eyeball and then he
plugged popeyes chicken after the game I
mean I love
about the Shawn Watson but I always like
this quote seem a lot well I appreciate
the compliment on my call Pat and and I
appreciate this call too immensely by
the way I caught it all Elizabeth Frank
and by the big Richard Nick was my maybe
my favorite highlight of this time well
you know I'm on a lot of FCC regulated
things I don't even know who you are
anymore Pat because you've got 50
million things going on I love uh always
love chatting with you
thanks for the call brother let's do it
again soon and I guess help me on your
show anytime come on
I would love to have you on my show I
know you're very busy as well and I
can't think enough you've always been
nothing about trying to be and I mean
this you need to call more games I like
when your voice is up there you're
really good at it thanks Patrick you
take care of yourself brother thanks
that's it that's Pat McAfee for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app